[Applaudissements]
c'est si fragile
c'est quand même un petit peu la télé
réalité aussi qui vous a apporté aussi
votre lot de drames et de souffrances et
néanmoins vous ne regrettez pas vous en
avez même refait par la suite sur l
origine des deux petits trous
je veux juste remercier mme mireille
dumas après beaucoup de tendresse pour
loana donc j'essaie d'être un peu douce
pour une fois l'eau mais malgré tout
vous ne regrettez pas ça vous m'avez
tellement de soucis
beaucoup de soucis mais aussi tellement
de joie soldats de bruit de voyage de
gilles défilé pour jean-paul gaultier et
tout ça moi je vais regarder à travers
le petit écran et j'étais là maintenant
face à gries retraire s'il vous dit que
ça valait le coup oui ça vaut le pauvre
est oui jean michel trou et wallons à
nager j'ai lu lance un papier
dernièrement vous aviez un qi de son 40
et donc jouer ça va c'est quand même
vous pécho vous avez un mec en ce moment
mais j'ai quelqu'un depuis trois ans
mais je sais qui est le style de loana
autour de la table ah ouais ouais ouais
c'est pas de ce côté là bravo julien
combes et vous n'avez que le convient
peu sexy oui je trouve que c'est
l'animateur le plus sexy
zizou zizou
[Applaudissements]
la maison est là bezos l abbé zoé
lamazou la raison des bisous et lévézou
et le biseau
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]